The state of a perpetrator's mental health is often the focus of news reports in the aftermath of mass shootings and other acts of violence. Legislators and the public want to be able to predict if and when a person will become violent. In this episode, forensic psychologist Joel Devoskin talks about why the stigma surrounding mental health is to blame and also how psychologists can help prevent more violence if they are just given the opportunity. I'm Audrey Hamilton and this is speaking of psychology. Joel DeVoskin teaches in the Department of Psychiatry at the University of Arizona. He is chairman of the Governor's Advisory Council on Behavioral Health for the state of Nevada. He's also a clinical and forensic psychologist.
在大规模枪击事件和其他暴力行为发生后，新闻报道往往将焦点对准施暴者的心理健康状况。立法者和公众希望能够预测一个人是否会以及何时会变得暴力。在本期节目中，法医心理学家乔尔·德沃斯金（Joel Devoskin）将探讨为什么应该归咎于围绕心理健康的污名化，以及如果给予心理学家机会，他们将如何帮助防止更多的暴力。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这里是《心理学话语》（Speaking of Psychology）。乔尔·德沃斯金在亚利桑那大学精神病学系任教。他是内华达州州长行为健康咨询委员会的主席。他同时也是一名临床和法医心理学家。
He served as an expert witness in several state and federal courts throughout the U.S., and he specializes in assessing a person's risk of violence to self and others, as well as workplace violence prevention. Welcome, Dr. DeVoskin. Thank you very much for having me. There have been several high-profile shootings in the news where there are the suspect has been described as having some sort of mental disorder, either officially or anecdotally. What sort of message is this sending to the general public about the association between mental
他曾担任美国多个州和联邦法院的专家证人，专长于评估个人对自己和他人实施暴力的风险，以及预防工作场所暴力。欢迎您，德沃斯金博士。非常感谢邀请我来。新闻中报道了几起备受瞩目的枪击事件，其中嫌疑人被官方或非官方地描述为患有某种精神障碍。这向广大公众传达了关于精神疾病与暴力之间联系的什么信息？它们之间是否存在联系？
illness and violence? Is there a link? Well, there's a lot of messages that it sends, and some of them are very inaccurate and, in fact, counterproductive and harmful. The short version is that while people with serious mental illness are slightly more likely to commit acts of violence than, people without mental illness, the risk that it creates is pretty small compared to other known risk factors, for example, current substance abuse. It's also true that a lot of the people that you read about, these anecdotes are played up by the media, and people overgeneralize from these very dramatic examples. So when you see somebody do something horrible, you think
嗯，它传达了很多信息，其中一些非常不准确，甚至适得其反且有害。简而言之，虽然患有严重精神疾病的人实施暴力行为的可能性比没有精神疾病的人略高，但它所带来的风险与其他已知的风险因素（例如当前滥用药物）相比相当小。同样真实的是，你在报道中读到的许多人，这些轶事都被媒体夸大了，人们从这些非常戏剧化的例子中过度概括。因此，当你看到某人做了一件可怕的事情时，你会认为
it happens more often than it actually does. So the facts are pretty clear that, first of all, mass homicide accounts for a very tiny percentage of all the gun deaths in the United States, like one or two percent. And even homicide is less of a problem in terms of gun deaths than suicide. Another example is where the electronic media focus on long guns like Bushmasters and assault weapons, they account for a very small percentage of gun violence in the United States. United States, the vast majority of gun violence has to do with handguns. So there's a lot of misinformation, and the press only cares about selling, or not the press, but the electronic media, mainly cable news, mainly care about selling airtime.
这种情况发生的频率比实际要高。所以事实非常清楚，首先，群体凶杀案只占美国所有枪支死亡人数的极小比例，大约百分之一或百分之二。而且，即使就枪支死亡而言，凶杀案作为问题的严重性也不如自杀。另一个例子是，当电子媒体关注诸如大毒蛇（Bushmasters）和突击武器等长枪时，它们只占美国枪支暴力的极小比例。在美国，绝大多数枪支暴力都与手枪有关。因此，有很多错误信息，媒体只关心销售，或者说不是媒体，而是电子媒体，主要是有限电视新闻，主要关心的只是出售播出时间。
So they put on the things that are the most dramatic, and that causes people to overgeneralize. The results of that is that it creates additional stigma about mental illness and actually discourages people from getting treatment. So it's bad for a lot of reasons. What role does mental health stigma play in the debate over gun violence and gun policy, specifically stigma? Well, again, the politicians have an unfortunate tendency to react to what is most publicized and also to react to anecdotes as opposed to solid research. And we don't know enough to really guide public policy. So stigma, which is sort of a collection of myths and stereotypes, tends to guide public policy far too much.
所以他们播放那些最戏剧化的内容，这导致人们过度概括。其结果是，它加剧了对精神疾病的污名化，并实际上阻止了人们寻求治疗。因此，它在很多方面都是有害的。心理健康污名化在关于枪支暴力和枪支政策的辩论中扮演了什么角色，特别是污名化？嗯，同样，政客们有一种不幸的倾向，即对最受宣传的事情做出反应，并对轶事而非扎实的研究做出反应。我们对指导公共政策的了解还远远不够。因此，污名化这种由神话和刻板印象构成的集合，往往在很大程度上过度主导了公共政策。
And as I said, much of it's incorrect. So we end up with policies that people tout as saying we did something, but in fact it's either not helpful or in some cases counterproductive. And we'd be far better off as a country if instead of relying on stigma, people were encouraging really good research about how to reduce gun violence rather than just react to these extreme cases and the stigma and myths and stereotypes. An example of this, you know, some legislators have been pressing for laws that prevent the sale of firearms to anyone who has ever been diagnosed with a mental illness.
正如我所说，其中大部分是不正确的。因此，我们最终得到的政策是人们吹嘘说我们做了一些事情，但事实上要么没有帮助，要么在某些情况下适得其反。如果我们作为一个国家，不是依赖污名化，而是鼓励真正优秀的研究，探讨如何减少枪支暴力，而不是仅仅对这些极端案例以及污名化、神话和刻板印象做出反应，我们的情况会好得多。这方面的一个例子是，你知道，一些立法者一直在敦促制定法律，禁止向任何曾被诊断患有精神疾病的人出售枪支。
Should mental health be taken into account when deciding who can own a firearm? If a person has schizophrenia, the likelihood that they will kill a stranger has been estimated, according to research, at 1 in 144,000. So it's popular for politicians to say, oh, I did something. You know, the myth is you'd have to be, quote, crazy to do something like this. So retrospectively, you look at people and you say, wow, this obviously, that guy should have been branded. But the truth is that most of the people, even of these anecdotes, were people who were very early on in their illness who had not been identified as seriously mentally ill, who wouldn't have been on the list anyway. There's a couple of exceptions to that. So for the most part, it's just stuff that's
在决定谁可以拥有枪支时，是否应将心理健康考虑在内？如果一个人患有精神分裂症，根据研究估计，他杀死陌生人的可能性是144,000分之一。因此，政客们喜欢说：“哦，我做了一件事。”你知道，这种神话是：你必须是“疯了”才会做出这样的事情。因此，当你回顾过去看人们时，你会说：“哇，这个人显然应该被贴上标签。”但事实是，甚至在这些轶事中的大多数人，都是那些在疾病非常早期阶段、尚未被确认为严重精神疾病患者的人，无论如何他们都不会在名单上。对此有几个例外。所以，在大多数情况下，这些只是
easy to sell as to say, I did something really important, but alcohol accounts for a great deal more violence than mental illness does. As a forensic psychologist who assesses people who might be a risk to themselves or to others, what challenges do you face in determining who will become dangerous? Well, there's a whole bunch of research about assessing the risk of dangerousness that looks at the traits of a person. But we know that all human behavior is an interaction between a human being and the circumstances or situations in which they find themselves.
很容易兜售的东西，可以用来宣称“我做了一件非常重要的事”，但酒精导致的暴力事件远比精神疾病要多。作为一名评估可能对自己或他人构成风险的人的法医心理学家，你在确定谁会变得危险时面临什么挑战？嗯，有很多关于评估危险风险的研究，这些研究着眼于个人的特征。但我们知道，所有人类行为都是人与他们所处的环境或情境之间相互作用的结果。
And it's very difficult to predict the situations that a person's going to be in in the future. We think that a better strategy is when you become aware of a person who is either uttering or posing threats, is then to look at the person in the context of the situation they're in and make recommendations to intervene and change that situation. Steve Hart, one of my colleagues and friends, calls these risk scenarios, is under what circumstances would this person be likely to harm somebody? That's much more helpful than saying this guy's a high-risk person based on these sort of all-or-nothing determinations. But there are a number of different methods of risk assessment, and many of them are really good. Some are actuarial, which help you look at the kind of overall risk that a person might present.
而且很难预测一个人未来将处于什么情境。我们认为，更好的策略是，当你意识到某人正在发出或构成威胁时，然后将这个人置于他们所处的环境背景中进行观察，并提出干预和改变这种环境的建议。我的同事兼朋友史蒂夫·哈特（Steve Hart）称这些为风险情境，即在什么情况下这个人最有可能伤害某人？这比基于这种非此即彼的判定说这家伙是高风险人员要有用得多。但是，有许多不同的风险评估方法，其中许多确实很好。有些是精算式的，可以帮助你了解一个人可能呈现的整体风险。
But it won't tell you how they're under what circumstances they will or won't. So even if you knew that somebody had a 50% chance, was in a group of people with a 50% chance of being violent, you don't know if they're in the 50 that will or the 50 that won't, and it may depend on the situations in which they find themselves. When you do risk assessment, risk assessment by itself isn't very important. What matters is the steps that are taken as a result. So that could be treatment, it could be intervening in the situations, it could be skill teaching for people.
但它不会告诉你他们将在什么情况下会或不会这样做。因此，即使你知道某人有50%的概率，处于有50%暴力倾向的人群中，你也不知道他们是会施暴的那50%还是不会施暴的那50%，这可能取决于他们所处的环境。当你进行风险评估时，风险评估本身并不是最重要的。重要的是由此采取的步骤。这可能是治疗，可能是干预环境，也可能是对人们进行技能培训。
Their goal is no longer to call people names. It's to actually prevent violence. What ways can mental health services be more effective and assessing and treating people who could present a danger to themselves or others. Well, in my opinion, the most important role of the public mental health system in preventing violence is not related to the treatment of serious mental illness, although that's very important for clinical reasons. But where we really want to see the public mental health system better funded and better
他们的目标不再是给别人贴标签。而是真正地防止暴力。心理健康服务可以通过哪些方式在评估和治疗可能对自身或他人构成危险的人方面变得更加有效？嗯，在我看来，公共心理健康系统在防止暴力方面最重要的作用与治疗严重精神疾病无关，尽管这出于临床原因非常重要。但我们真正希望看到公共心理健康系统获得更多资金和更好支持的地方
capable of intervening is in crisis response. So when somebody feels depressed, enraged, insignificant, they have access to a firearm, maybe they're drinking too much that night, maybe they just got fired. And so it's like this perfect storm of despair. It would be very important for our system to be able to give that person really competent suicide prevention services in this crisis to give them an alternative to. ending their life as a way of ending their psychological pain. And that's something, and it's not a criticism of the people who are doing this work. There's some wonderful first responders, both in
具备干预能力的是危机响应。因此，当某人感到沮丧、愤怒、微不足道时，他们有机会接触到枪支，也许那天晚上他们喝了太多酒，也许他们刚刚被解雇。所以这就好象是一场绝望的完美风暴。对于我们的系统来说，能够在这场危机中为该这个人提供真正称职的自杀预防服务，为他们提供一种替代方案，将是非常重要的。结束生命作为结束心理痛苦的一种方式。这是某种东西，这并不是对那些正在做这项工作的人的批评。有一些非常棒的第一响应者，无论是在
mental health and paramedics and police. But if you get good at this, you can't keep doing it because the pay's not very good. If you want to raise a family, people quit those jobs and go into other things so they can make better living. So we need more money so we can have more timely, competent crisis response services by the public mental health as well as other first responder systems. And that would, I think, dramatic, every time somebody commits a mass homicide, they're ending their life. They're either going to commit suicide or they're going to get the police to shoot them or they're going to go to prison or hospital for the rest of their life. They've given up. Their life is over. And we know how to prevent suicide. We just don't do it.
心理健康、护理人员还是警察。但如果你精通此道，你就无法坚持下去，因为薪水不是很好。如果你想养家糊口，人们就会辞掉这些工作，转行做别的事情，以便能维持更好的生计。因此，我们需要更多的资金，以便公共心理健康系统以及其他第一响应系统能够提供更及时、更有能力的危机应对服务。我认为这将会非常戏剧化，每次有人犯下群体凶杀案时，他们都在结束自己的生命。他们要么会自杀，要么会让警察向他们开枪，或者他们将在监狱或医院度过余生。他们已经放弃了。他们的生活结束了。我们知道如何预防自杀。我们只是没有去做。
We know a ton about suicide prevention, and yet the suicide rates in the United States haven't gone down because we haven't made a good societal investment in suicide prevention and crisis responding. And that, I feel, is very important and would make a very big difference. I also would say that we need a lot more information and data, and Congress has, to an unfortunate extent, stifled research on preventing gun violence. So the national violent death reporting system has only exists in, I think, 16 states. That should be nationwide. CDC, the Center for Disease Control, is discouraged from doing research on gun violence.
我们对自杀预防了解得非常透彻，然而美国的自杀率并没有下降，因为我们没有对自杀预防和危机应对进行良好的社会投资。我觉得这非常重要，并且会带来巨大的改变。我还想说，我们需要更多的信息和数据，而国会在很大程度上扼杀了关于预防枪支暴力的研究。因此，国家暴力死亡报告系统只存在于，我认为，16个州。这应该是全国性的。疾病控制与中心（CDC）被劝阻不要对枪支暴力进行研究。
And it's not about the Second Amendment. There's going to be guns in the streets of America for as long as I'm alive. But that doesn't mean that we can't learn more about how to prevent violence, violent use of these guns and inappropriate use of these guns. through a variety of mechanisms, including public information, training, safety training. There's a lot of different things that we, and we just don't know which things work because there hasn't been enough research done. Okay, Dr. DeVoskin, thank you so much for taking the time to speak with us. I appreciate you're having me. Thank you.
这与第二修正案无关。只要我还活着，美国街头就会一直有枪。但这并不意味着我们不能通过各种机制了解更多关于如何防止暴力、暴力使用这些枪支以及不当使用这些枪支的方法，这些机制包括公共信息、培训、安全培训。有很多不同的事情我们可以做，但我们只是不知道哪些事情有效，因为还没有进行足够的研究。好的，德沃斯金博士，非常感谢您抽出时间与我们交谈。我很感激您的到来。谢谢。
For more information on DeVoskin's research and to hear more episodes, go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关德沃斯金研究的更多信息并收听更多节目，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《心理学话语》栏目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。该期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。